You've been using MathQuill for the past few lessons, and hopefully you've
gotten used to entering exponents and fractions using it, making your equations
and expressions look super pretty. But now that we're starting to use radicals,
we need to use MathQuill in a new way. I already showed you earlier how to enter
square roots in MathQuill, you type backslash sqrt space, and then whatever goes
inside. The MathQuill also let's us write nthroots. So, it allows us to type
radical signs and then type whatever number we want for the index, and then, of
course, enter whatever we want underneath the radical. To write a radical sign
when you need to write a number you just write backslash nthroot space, and then
whatever number you want to go in this spot up here. To get out of typing in the
index spot, to typing underneath the radical sign again, you need to type a
right arrow key. So, try out these first two where you can use some instructions
on what to type. And then, for your two challenge problems, I'd like you to
experiment combining the different functionalities in MathQuill that we've been
using with this new set of tools. So, we have, for example, in this term,
exponents combined with radicals and fractions all in one. So, if you can do
this, you're an official MathQuill pro. Just experiment, just have fun to see
how incredibly powerful this tool is.